ti monsieur le premier ministre la
parole et quand monsieur dino cinieri ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre et je veux y associer mes
collègue laurent wauquiez pour le salon
d yves nicolin monsieur le premier
ministre les maires ruraux sont en
colère contre vous et votre gouvernement
après avoir baissé drastiquement les
dotations après leur avoir imposé une
réforme des rythmes scolaires aussi
coûteuse et inutile
vous voulez maintenant anéantir le
niveau de proximité préféré des français
qu'est la commune pour les petites
communes rurales
la dgf s'élève à 64 euros par habitant
et par an ce qui est largement
insuffisant alors qu'elle atteint 128
euros dans les grandes villes
non non monsieur le premier ministre les
habitants des communes rurales ne sont
pas des demies français alors un effort
financier supplémentaire sera le
bienvenu votre projet de loi pourtant la
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
république va amplifier l'opposition
entre ville et campagne
elle ne réglera pas les problèmes
d'équité et d'accès aux services publics
en milieu rural
les élus locaux ruraux font un travail
admirable pour leurs administrés
ils sont dévoués engagé pour à jeu et ne
compte pas le temps donné pour leur
village qu'ils sont de véritables
poumons verts de la france et je veux
ici avec l'ensemble de mes collègues
rendre hommage à tous les maires
adjoints et conseillers municipaux des
communes rurales
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
empêché les maires et des conseillers
municipaux des petites communes de
prendre leurs propres décisions en
matière de logement d'urbanisme de
maintien des services ou encore
d'accessibilité pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite avec la loi notre les
maires en sont réduits à célébrer des
mariages
alors monsieur le premier ministre
écoutez enfin les maires ruraux et
revenait sur cette réforme qui va
dénaturer notre pays est dévasté nos
territoires
la parole est à monsieur andré vallini
secrétaire d'état chargé de la réforme
territoriale
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député cinieri je vous connais bien et
depuis longtemps nous sommes de la même
région rhône-alpes et vous m'aviez
habitués dans nos dans nos conversations
à moindou trans c'est moins caricature
le gouvernement ne veut pas du tout la
disparition des communes comme j'ai
coutume de le dire aux maires ruraux que
je rencontre moi aussi dans toute la
france la commune
elle est dans l'adn de la république
française personne ne touchera aux
communes pour autant nous sommes tous
d'accord et sur tous les bancs pour
renforcer l'intercommunalité pour faire
à plusieurs beaucoup mieux que ce qu'on
peut faire tout seul les élus ruraux en
sont les premiers convaincu
l'intercommunalité depuis 20 ans est
monté en puissance
c'est une révolution silencieuse qui a
eu lieu qui permet de remédier à
l'émiettement communal
donc nous allons renforcer ce mouvement
intercommunale dans tous les territoires
ruraux quelles que soient les étiquettes
politiques de mer et s'ouvre ils n'ont
pas d'étiquette politique
ils sont d'accord pour ce renforcement
de l'intercommunalité de la même façon
que vous avez voté à la quasi-unanimité
la loi sur les communes nouvelles qui
venait de christine pires bonne députée
socialiste du puy de dôme et de jacques
pélissard député ump du jura sur ces
questions on peut trouver des accords
républicain trans partisan en oubliant
les caricatures et les outrances en fait
un dernier mot monsieur le député les
territoires ruraux font l'objet d'une
attention particulière du gouvernement
la dotation d'équipement des territoires
ruraux la detr a été renforcée de 200
millions d'euros cette année plus de 100
millions d'euros nous sommes passés de
600 à 800 millions d'euros
si ça ce n'est pas le signe de l'intérêt
que porte le gouvernement aux
territoires ruraux qu'est ce que c'est
enfin gagnon monsieur le député vous
critiquez la baisse des notations qui
s'inscrit dans un plan d'économies
global de 50 milliards d'euros 50
milliards d'euros d'économies sur les
finances publiques
la formation politique à laquelle vous
appartenez l'ump hier les républicains
aujourd'hui proposé 150 millions 150
milliards d'euros d'économies vous les
prenez ou et vous demandez combien aux
collectivités locales vous ne dites
jamais ça jamais
merci